this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode as we've had a ton of
requests for it right since the door of
all time jonathan is finally going to be
taking a look at some of the weapons
from payday 2. uh now the less said
about the the gunsmithing of this the
better even though it's only a game it
still feels like blasphemy against this
very rare historic firearm to see it
effectively chopped up and with an acog
on it it's not right we actually
recorded so much with jonathan about pay
a2 that we'll be publishing two episodes
for this game so make sure to subscribe
if you want to check out the second
episode coming soon and if there are any
other games guns and mechanics that you
guys want to see jonathan break down let
us know in the comment section below
right let's take a look at payday 2.
not the most usual site in gaming
the
imi galil which as i'm sure a lot of you
know is a sort of cousin of the
kalashnikov it's so i i tend to call it
a derivative rather than a variant it
came in 7.62 nato and 5.56 nato flavors
as well as a couple of different models
and what we've got here is the arm
automatic rifle machine gun i think
that's supposed to stand for from memory
and it's in 7.62 as we can tell from the
sort of the length of the receiver slash
bolt and the depth of that magazine
that's definitely a big chunky cartridge
in there why is it in the game well if
you know your
movies
and your guns the 5.56 version of this
was in heat which is a massive
inspiration for payday so that's why
it's here
complete with bipod
it's the same basic rifle but it is in a
different caliber i'm not quite sure why
that is except that they may well have
wanted a more powerful rifle for
balancing purposes something a little
bit different we actually have one here
and you can see that they have modeled
the the magazine pretty closely it's got
the same pattern of reinforcing ribbing
on it some some pressed in something
pressed out of the sheet metal and it's
um yeah it's it's pretty good this this
is actually actually a different variant
so it has a different fore end on it
different butt stock but it's the same
basic rifle in the same
caliber so this is the gleal sniper not
the arm but it's the closest that we
have
okay i'm looking at a couple of details
on this thing that didn't seem to be on
the actual weapon and i'm not so sure
about the line on the left side of the
receiver that that maybe may have been
added by the artist it's not these are
just blocky machined receivers they
don't have much detail on them so maybe
a bit of detail added there i also
noticed a line on the rear of the top
cover that was literally a line on the
3d model but that's actually part of the
top cover a reinforcement for the top
cover on the gleal so that's actually an
extra piece of metal that is spot welded
on and wraps around and they've seen
that on a photo or something and try to
replicate it as a two-part top cover
effectively that's not what it is this
this is the kind of nerdy detail that
you notice when you do this for a living
and you have access to um stuff like
this okay as ever not a criticism just
something that i've noticed
it's a kel-tec i don't think we have any
caltech firearms in the collection here
which is not deliberate um it's just
that they're not something it's not
something we've come across or had the
opportunity to acquire an example of i
would because
they tend to be innovative um and low
cost
so they are
culturally interesting firearms and i
would like an example of of something
for the collection uh if anyone from
from caltech is watching
so this is the sub 2000 which is a
folding sort of packable pistol caliber
carbine with as you can see the magazine
in the pistol grip it makes for a very
wacky first person view because it looks
so unlike anything else the barrel
sticking out the end with no you know no
visible gas system because it doesn't
have one and the weird sort of tubular
butt stock arrangement the cocking
handle underneath at the back it's all
very unconventional and it's all geared
up to folding into a compact shape for
easy portability now that would lend
itself very much to a game like this in
terms of being concealable so let's see
if we actually get to conceal it so i
don't i don't remember ever seeing this
when i did play the game
got a shield over here right yes this
thing does fold in game which you i
guess you might expect as at least a uh
deploy animation but it does actually
appear to be the gameplay element as
well so it will i presume it's the
treated the same in the game as
holstering a pistol under a jacket or
something such that no one knows you've
got a firearm until you pull it out and
deploy it though it's a it's a good
choice for this game albeit when i tried
to play payday two years ago i couldn't
stealth my way through about more than
about six feet before i was detected
so it wouldn't really matter for me but
uh in reality it is it is foldable and
because it takes glock magazines
if you have just a normal pistol
glock 17 magazine in it you could just
open it up and use it as we see here if
you wanted the long magazine that that
i'm seeing in the game you'd have to
take that out which means it would be a
take it out open it up fit the magazine
[ __ ] it as well so it would be a little
bit more time consuming you couldn't
just leave them the 33 round magazines
sticking out the bottom of the gun
because it would not fit
down your trousers or whatever
right and we have abandoned all pretense
at realism and we have a shoulder fired
mini gun or is it meant to be the the
micro gun so for those of you don't know
the minigun is called the minigun
because it's the mini version of the
vulcan 20 millimeter rotary cannon
gatling gun and we have an episode a
loadout episode on the minigun that you
should check out if you haven't seen it
before the micro gun is as the name
might imply so the mini gun is 7.62
millimeter mini compared to the 20
millimeter and the micro gun is 5.56
millimeter micro compared to those other
two guns it does exist it is a an
experimental variant not as far as i
know adopted for military use and not in
use by anyone else as far as i know but
it does exist i can't say which this is
the barrels look very heavy although
they're short they look very very thick
i don't know what the game thinks this
caliber is oh this gun is is which
caliber this gun is in this shoulder
stock is
a bit bizarre it almost looks like a man
portable air defense weapon type grip
stock that's complete fantasy wouldn't
work particularly well but then shoulder
firing any 3 000 round per minute rotary
gun is is a bad idea looks like we've
got the battery and the feed system
built into this contraption so they have
at least thought about if physics
weren't a thing
how you would actually create a package
that you could carry around and use from
the shoulder from the hip which is a lot
more than most games do they generally
just have the the bear gun no ammunition
feed no power supply nothing give him
credit for that but it's not for me it's
not a natural fit with a heist
game
okay i i've got a bad feeling about this
because we've got dual wielded assault
rifles with
what look like 60 round large magazines
fitted to them so
chaos is going to ensue i think unless
unless the game is going to try to
realistically depict what would happen
if you did that and you weren't arnold
schwarzenegger
we'll find out in a moment but these are
the bren 805.
think of it as a parallel to i don't
know the acr or the scar in america a
modern take on the ar 18 operating
system 5.56 or whatever caliber you
you purchase it in there are a couple of
options available what you don't want to
do is shoot them one in each hand
so let's have a look
right as predicted there's there's a nod
toward the uncontrollability of firing a
556 short barrel rifle fully automatic
one in each hand but nowhere near enough
you pretty much have to put them under
your arms
or have absolutely massive arms and
hands and everything else not advisable
for um bank robbers or anyone else
really now the game seems to permit this
aberrant behavior because in the
gunsmith it calls this a submachine gun
it's really not there was at least an
argument to say that a very short
barrelled assault rifle could be
classified as submachine gun but i don't
think anyone with a technical mind would
refer to a short barrel 5.56 millimeter
select fire firearm as a submachine gun
for whatever reason the developers have
put it into that bracket and therefore
you can shoot one in each hand and
vaguely control it not great
gameplay-wise because
got
or is it because the long barrel implies
that it's the fs 2000 s for
semi-automatic now we featured the f2000
before in this series
this is a normal f2000 so it is
selective fire it does have the
conventional length barrel now the
reason i've got it out again this time
is to talk briefly about the tactical
version because that's what we see in
payday 2. now in reality ignoring the fs
2000 but i'm not ignoring it entirely
because the railed handguard on the game
version is basically the one for the
semi-automatic fs 2000 because the
military slash law enforcement version
had a an optional lower handguard that
we haven't got that had a try rail on
the front here so you could put a
forward grip on it you could put a laser
on the side or whatever but it wasn't a
tri-rail full length it was just little
little chunks at the front here and then
you think well there's a surely the
tactical version has a picatinny rail on
it well yes and it was marketed
separately as the tactical version
however if you press this
button
push up and pull off the plastic cover
all f2000s are the tactical version
so if you ordered the tactical version
you were just not getting the scope or
the or the um
cover for the scope you could then fit
of course whatever optical sight you
wished onto the polymer rail underneath
that cover and that's what if you've
ever wondered don't imagine you have but
if you've ever wondered what the
standard f2000 optic looks like
underneath that's what it looks like so
that's
that's how you make an f2000 tactical
something i've talked about before is
the so guns and games where it appears
they just rip the magazine straight out
without pressing a magazine catch well
in this case it's plausible-ish because
the way this is set up is you push up
the magazine catch
as you rip out the magazine so it's the
closest we get to the video game gun
shoving it in removing it without any
kind of catch it also fits the very
exaggerated movements most first-person
shooters are very exaggerated in how
they do their movements if they haven't
mocap
motion captured someone with some real
skill doing very swift reloads and
things then they will tend to very
exaggerated motions so that you can see
what's going on and perhaps to
artificially slow down the reload well
that kind of works that kind of is
true for this in that in here
is a gasket a rubber seal and you are
overcoming that not so much when you put
it in but when you pull it out so it
does it almost feel it looks like a
video game gun and it kind of feels like
one when you use it as well
right another payday 2 gun that we
haven't got
this is the cry precision 612. i've yet
to see this in the wild as it were
really interesting design um a road you
know revolver shotgun double action you
pull through on the trigger and the
cylinder revolves to the next chamber
and fires it in one pull and you can
well as you see it here it's a it's a
firearm a shotgun if you strip it down
you can fit its receiver complete with
the pistol grip or you can there's a
different form of receiver for it as
well and attach it as an under barrel
launch launcher an under parallel device
on a rifle or a carbine so like a almost
like a transformer i don't know from the
footage i saw at the time it seemed like
it had an awful lot of recoil depending
on the on the ammunition the the reload
involves taking out the whole cylinder
and replacing it it depends how how
economically the cylinders are made as
to whether that's a problem for users
because normally magazines are quite
cheap yeah but it's visually quite
distinctive it's something different as
always as we always say on on this
series
you need variety
yeah from what i've seen of this thing
firing it has a lot more recoil than is
depicted in the game and
someone is trolling me again by uh yeah
cheers dave
by putting a charm on the gun although
it is at least a gun a tiny gun on your
gun it's some sort of flintlock pistol
brass barrel thing but yeah he knows
that winds me up
so apart from the recoil aspect
it's a pretty good game shotgun because
we're seeing guys taken down from what
is probably fair to say are realistic
shotgun engagement distances we often
don't see that in video games for the
very obvious reason that not all guns
should be capable of doing everything
otherwise you'd only use a shotgun now i
guess the limitation here is in the
magazine capacity of only six rounds
hence the name 612 six rounds of 12
gauge ammunition in case you hadn't
figured that one out
now i didn't realize this was in the
game it's our old chum the vaulter or
walther wa2000 that
famous but unicorn-esque bullpup 7.62
marksman's rifle well legitimately a
sniper rifle is engineered like the
psg-1 engineered by germans to be a true
sniper rifle that's semi-automatic very
distinctive looking has appeared in in
media a fair bit uh this one was
actually on the set of the living
daylights now different
in terms of
well this is the scope that came with
ours i don't know of others that were an
option on this but i'm guessing that's
not the correct scope otherwise though
is
pretty good it's always handy when you
can look at the actual thing it even has
the
textured section here with the with the
dip in it which is for
your
rear hand to support it at the rear a
bit like a light machine gun it even
models that so i think they've done a
pretty good job my grasp of german is
essentially non-existent but i happen to
know that laban sauger means life sucker
which is a little more on the nose as a
name than wa 2000
and not a name that i imagine a german
arms company would ever use but um
not not inaccurate i dare say shown to
be pretty pretty powerful which it ought
to be the power level in the game is
important clearly because of the enemies
with heavy armor and ballistic shields
so there is a bit of precision shooting
going on here using the scope but a lot
of the there's quite a lot of hip firing
going on more than you would normally
see with a sniper rifle and that's
presumably uh to do with the armor
now the less said about the the
gunsmithing of this the better because
even though it's only a game it still
feels like blasphemy against this very
rare
cold war era
historic firearm to see it effectively
chopped up and with an acog on it it's
not right
i like that suppressor sound effect
sounds quite realistic although it
sounds more realistic for something like
556 than for 762. i think i'd expect
more of a gunshot noise with a
suppressed 762. limitations of software
hardware my ears my memory
thank you very much for watching as
always if you'd like to support the work
that we do here at the royal armouries
you can hit the description and you'll
find links in there to ways that you can
donate or join up and become a member of
the royal armouries museum we also have
social media outlets that you can you
can look up and our own youtube channel
featuring yours truly so if you're
interested in that head over to our
channel otherwise we'll see you again
next week thanks again for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you